[Music]
hi I'm Emmy eligible actor Aziz Ansari
and I'm here to tell you about a very
exciting new product I'm endorsing
they're called Aziz Ansari sorry they're
sexy they're luxurious and they're the
only sari with my face on sure there are
plenty of other celebrity endorse Ahri's
on the market but to any of those bozos
have the word sari in their name I don't
think so
but Aziz why choose your sari over the
others
good question hired actress I start with
the finest imported Chinese silk
handpicked by our team of renowned
fabric buyers then each sari is
hand-stitched by a team of expert
tailors finally these guys take a cut
out of my face cover the sari and glue
and slap my face the results speak for
themselves
so if you're working out at the gym
sorry time going out to the club sorry
time raking leaves on a crisp autumn day
pondering the arrogance of man sorry
time sorry time sorry time but don't
take it from me listen to these
endorsements from other Indian American
celebrities these sarees are an insult
to thousands of years of Indian
tradition I can't a good faith do Deepak
get my sari today before they're gone or
else you'll be sorry come on guys it's
terrible order your Aziz Ansari sorry
today only 5 9999 call now and we'll
throw in a gene Hackman gene testing
together the best
celebrity-endorsed direct-to-consumer
gene [ __ ] dick Mexico has to offer
[Applause]
you